[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday September 29th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
earlier this month the crypto platform
ethereum underwent a major change the
long-awaited ethereum emerged changed
how transactions on the network are
processed with the goal of reducing the
platform's environmental impact
in the lead-up to the shift the price of
ether the cryptocurrency tied to the
ethereum network nearly doubled but
since then the value of ether has fallen
drastically
so what's behind the reversal and how
long can it last
joining us to discuss that is our crypto
reporter Paul Vina hi Paul thanks for
joining me hi Paul one of the big things
that happened with the ethereum merge is
that it switched from a verification
system called a proof of work model to a
proof-of-stake model can you start by
reminding us what the difference is
between those two systems so I mean in a
very brief nutshell
the proof of work system
required ethereum's miners the people
that actually do the validating of
transactions to expend a certain amount
of computing power in order to have the
privilege of being part of the network
and you can earn money on it is very
profitable if you can do it at scale but
that's basically what you do you have to
put out Computing energy as a cost of
doing business what they have switched
to is a system where you're staking
money as your cost of doing business of
being what they now call a validator and
you are a node on the network and you're
processing transactions and you can earn
a little bit of money from that and then
of course the the big advantage of that
is that it is far more environmentally
friendly ethereum's energy usage went
down by about 99 after this software
upgrade so that that was the primary
reason for doing it how did that affect
the miners those who were kind of
creating The Ether cryptocurrency
basically it wiped out their business
this model ethereum miners had a
business where they bought Hardware to
process transactions and then they
hadn't built an entire business around
that and overnight that business
disappeared so those miners could either
take their machines and try to find a
different proof of work
cryptocurrency that would allow them to
keep doing that they could Scuttle their
hardware and just give up or they could
go in onto ethereum in the new model of
staking and put some money up so their
business model was it was eviscerated
overnight and so what are those miners
doing now with the ethereum that they
have well one of the things you saw in
the lead up to this big software switch
was the balance of ethereum that these
miners were holding there was a big
surge it went up a lot because they were
trying to get in their Last Licks so
they were mining as much as possible
they're doing a lot of work they're
holding on to it and then right around
the time of it you could see them start
selling so the price had gone up in
anticipation of this they turned up the
volume so to speak so they could mine as
much ether as possible and they sold at
the top
so you have these big miners selling off
after the merge but apart from that have
there been any hiccups since it happened
there haven't been any major hiccups and
that's a good thing there really could
have been the issue now becomes and this
is really with any software upgrade
anywhere this happens is well was there
anything in the code that is a problem a
bug that we didn't know about and it's
happened in the past on other upgrades
it's you know there's a history of it
you know something else that people seem
to be looking out for are maybe some
regulatory issues you know since the
merge we've heard the Securities and
Exchange Commission chair Gary Gensler
say that now ethereum might fall under
the sec's regulatory overview can you
explain that and how ethereum is
reacting this was one of the
probably more unexpected developments so
look this has been a big issue among
government Regulators what are
cryptocurrencies how do we Define them
how do we characterize them and regulate
them and there's been a big question of
whether cryptocurrencies are securities
are they Commodities you know what are
they and there have been different
answers to that and the sec's answer for
a while they've codified it but they're
sort of shorthand has been well that
Bitcoin and ethereum ownership is so
diffuse of the network itself that they
actually do operate like more like
Commodities than Securities they are not
securities
so Gary Gensler came out and said you
know what after the software upgrade now
that the model is you put up money and
you get paid for it that actually to him
he said it that kind of sounds like
ethereum could now be a security
so that is going to be something that
people in the ethereum world are going
to have to just pay attention to and
keep an eye on
you know we're talking about the drop in
ether's price but the market has been
pretty volatile lately I mean is there
anything different going on here
well you know stocks have been following
bitcoin's been following all these
cryptocurrencies have been falling and
for a little while ethereum was in its
own bubble really because there was a
lot of drummed up excitement over this
software upgrade now that the software
upgrade has been implemented and it's
over now ethereum is sort of starting to
fall back into the general malaise of
the rest of the world of risk assets
all right that's our reporter Paul Vina
thanks for joining us Paul yep thanks
for having me on
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]